فقد المليارديرات حول العالم ما يقرب من
تريليونير دولار نتحدث عن 2000 مليار
دولار في عام 20 22 وفقا لمجلات فرصه خسر
اصحاب المليارات في الولايات المتحده 660
مليار دولار وهي تعادل ثلث القيمه
الاجماليه العالميه وهو اعلى معدل في اي
بلد وفقا لاحصاءات فورس حيث انخفضت اسعار
اسهم شركه التكنولوجيا بسبب ارتفاع اسعار
الفائده وارتفاع معدلات التضخم وتدهور
الاقتصاد اليوم خفض سهم كسلا بواقع احد
10% وهو همم ما اسهم باغلاق السهم على
تراجع فقد تراجعت همم اسهم كسله بنسبه 73%
عن اعلى مستوى لها في نوفمبر 20 21 في
منخفض السهم بنسبه
69% في عام 2022 صحيفه
ستستمر في وقف الانتاج لمده اسبوع في
منشاتها في شنغهاي لمواجه صعود جديد من
اصابته كورونا داخل قوتها العامل الصينيه
وهو ما يفسر هذا
التراجع الان هناك بعض من الارتفاع نتحدث
عن عن اثنين فاصل سبعه بالمئه تقريبا
[موسيقى]